[Music]
hi there and welcome to the sixth
episode on sre and devops
my name is Seth and I'm a developer
advocate at Google focused on
infrastructure and operations and hi I'm
Liz I site reliability engineer or SRA
at Google where I teach Google cloud
customers how to build and operate
reliable services so Seth I have an
error budget now and it's based on the
level of reliability that my customers
expect but I don't want to have to wait
months to find out whether or not I'm
going to meet my error budget definitely
collecting all of that data can be time
consuming that's why you need a risk
analysis a risk what an analysis of what
items or risks that might cause you to
not meet your SLO I see yeah I know all
the ways that my system has failed in
the past and I can think of many
different ways that my system might fail
in the future but how does that help me
figure out if my error but it is
realistic so you need to figure out how
often each failure is likely to happen
and how severe it will be if and when it
happens I see but that still doesn't
help me compare the impact on my error
budget how do I know if the high
severity but infrequent form of outage
is better or worse than a frequent but
low level degree of degradation right so
that's actually the secret you just have
to multiply those metrics together here
let me show you tell me about one of
your common incidents or failure modes
that you're worried about so for example
I have a primary database that I have to
backup every month and it takes the
entire database down for two hours every
single time so that means that your time
between failures is roughly 30 days
every month and then your impact
duration is 120 minutes it also impacts
your entire user base since during that
time the entire system is offline that
makes sense so that means you'd have
about 120 minutes times 12 months times
100% of your user base which is about
1440 bad minutes per year and my error
budget says that I'm supposed to achieve
two and a half 9s or 99.5% reliability
over the year meaning that I can have
about 2600 bad minutes per year right so
that means your monthly database
downtime is consuming half of your error
budget but I'm sure that's not the only
kind of downtime you're seeing no as an
example every couple of weeks people
complain but the system is slow on
Friday afternoons because everyone is
trying to build and test their code
before they go home for the weekend yeah
that happens and like every software
development
so it's so slow that it causes half our
users to be unhappy with us and what's
worse is it takes us half an hour for
the support tickets to come in and then
half an hour to actually provision more
capacity so that is probably not very
good right yeah so if I were to put this
into the same framework I'd say that
this is a 60 minute outage 30 minutes to
detect and 30 minutes to resolve times
26 times per year affecting about half
of your user base and that's 780 bad
minutes per year right so this outage
would wind up being about half as bad as
the database backup downtime so that
makes a lot of sense
great so we can fill out these
calculations together for any other
sources of outages that you'd like to
catalog great I'll get right to it
[Music]
okay now I'm done with that so now that
you've compiled all of the risk data we
can sort the outages by the number of
bad minutes per year indeed as we
suspected the monthly database outage is
consuming the majority of your error
budget combined with these other small
sources of outages it's clear that
you're going to exceed your error budget
that's not really good well but it's not
all bad news since we've gathered our
estimates and quantified this data we
can find out what things will bring us
back under the air budget for instance
anything that consumes about 25 percent
of the error budget or more is something
that we want to address that makes sense
and if I address all the large risks and
I still wind up exceeding my error
budget what do i do then so then you
need to pick a combination of risks to
address that will bring you within the
budget not necessarily all of the
largest ones right because some of the
larger risks I can't necessarily address
without rewriting the whole system
that'll take time so you're saying that
if I accumulate enough of these smaller
things and fix them they'll potentially
bring me back within my error budget
right so now you have a plan for how to
estimate risk and a way to create plans
to stay within your error budget
alternatively if there's no way to
mitigate all of that risk you now have
numerical evidence to go back to your
key stakeholders to revisit the
possibility of a different SLO that
would give you a larger error budget
thanks Seth and thanks to everyone for
watching this episode hopefully this is
helpful for teams trying to put DevOps
into practice through SOE techniques I'm
really excited to figure out how to set
up effective alerts for our service so
we can know whether we're in danger of
violating our SLO
on the next episode hey Liz what's that
button down there oh that's the like
button you should press it if you
enjoyed this and and this one over here
that's subscribe button so you can find
out when we post your next episode
[Music]